un vendredi soir à berlin
un club de jeunes comme tant d'autres à
l'ouest où est la différence
peut-être en ce sens ce club où l'on
danse sur les derniers tubes où l'on
sert et voire modérément d'ailleurs de
l'alcool est tenue gérée et animée par
le ft viotte la jeunesse allemande libre
l'organisation de masse du parti
socialiste unifié pour l'ensemble des
jeunes travailleurs et étudiants compris
dans tous les autres domaines en herbe
et à la compétition n'est pas exclu cela
se passe sur scène au micro et dans la
langue de son choix
le clip est bien que les pcb les matins
mais sa voix
berlin est aussi le siège d'une
université au passé brillant
l'université humboldt à deux pas de là
une bibliothèque où venaient étudier la
dîmière ilitch minimes pour ce qui
concerne l'étude des langues étrangères
nous avons d'abord le russe est en
seconde langue l'anglais et le français
non le français est une langue à option
parmi d'autres mais en règle générale on
a choisi pas systématiquement en plus
des études et de la spécialisation
choisi plus tard il ya naturellement
l'enseignement de base du marxisme
léninisme en trois parties distinctes en
première année philosophie et le
matérialisme dialectique en 2e année
l'économie politique du capitalisme et
du socialisme enfin en troisième année
l'économie en régime communiste et il
est à souligner que cet enseignement de
base du marxisme est obligatoire dans
notre propre intérêt d'ailleurs c'est
aussi un plaisir parce que précisément
face aux problèmes politiques actuels
aux questions qui se posent à nous et
qui nous préoccupe
cela nous aide rapporté nous mêmes les
répondre et a expliqué nous mènent les
événements mondiaux
cet apprentissage de la vie en société
socialiste se fait dès le plus jeune âge
et notamment dans le cadre
d'organisations comme les jeunes
pionniers au foulard bleu qui sont la
relève de demain
you can't buy traduction littérale
consécration de la jeunesse c'est une
sorte de confirmation laïque elle
remplace la communion à caractère
religieux et marque l'entrée solennelle
des jeunes de 14 ans dans leur vie de
citoyen de la république démocratique
après avoir écouté les discours et juré
fidélité à la patrie socialiste on
reçoit un texte de la constitution de la
rda puis le dîner de fête achevée on
risquera ses premiers pas de danse sur
le parquet de la salle d'honneur de
l'école ou de l'usiné la république
démocratique allemande aujourd'hui à
l'âge de plus du tiers de ses citoyens
25 ans contrairement à ses aînés
la génération montante n'a pas d'autres
souvenirs pas d'autre horizon que ceux
du socialisme elle n'a pas connu les
drames de la guerre et les difficultés
énormes de l'après-guerre immédiat
la jeunesse de r&b a élevé dans le
sérail participera ensuite pendant 18
mois à la défense de la patrie
socialiste sous l'uniforme
une étape de plus dans la vie
une étape de plus aussi dans la
consolidation d'un régime donc après
tout au-delà des problèmes des soucis
des rêves inutile on souhaite vraiment
qu'il réussisse parce qu'aussi qu'on a
sa fierté